[Music]
soon next dorian warriors will
assassinate me
i have a child on the other side of the
world
take heart in your grief you are king
now be
as your father bark orders at me throw
things at me
it will make you happy
prepare the royal jet
we are going back to america
oh hell no your majesty
so what you doing back here idiot i mean
i've just discovered that i may have a
son here in this land i'm a child
support she getting from
the king pays no child support no tie
support for 30 years and you came back
you was a dummy yes
nice and tasty you wouldn't do it hello
want some tickets man no thank you
i am king akim jaffer king of zumunda
and i believe that you are the heir to
the throne of zamunda
my first born child and my only son
yes it's my father
i've come back for my son jamunda
wakanda connecticut i don't know where
you're from exactly
but i've been enforcing this boy's life
since he was born i'm lavelle johnson
all right i don't need no handouts
hey yo uh you know i'm thinking
who am i to say no to becoming a prince
fighting is not for pretty girls and
princesses
your king and father should have taught
you to be
more polite
[Music]
perhaps now you would like to solve your
problems
diplomatically i'm listening
that's the last surprise hey what's up
hi
what's up sam hey look i'm gonna hug you
cause i'm a hugger hey quinn
i'm sorry i slept with your man what is
going on here
oh children children i would love for
you to meet
your brother and my name is mary how you
doing just
call me your second mom but you really
don't have to
girls i mean but you should though cause
i kind of am
well look at us just one big happy
mundane american
aristocratic blended family i just like
the kardashians
just discovered that i may have a son
here in this land how much child support
are she getting from the king pays no
child support no ties up off for 30
years and you came back
[Music]
he's supposed to be like the prince of
wakanda wakanda is a fictional place not
everybody so munda has a very
real nation i don't need no handouts
wait a minute hi i'm no pet okay
[Applause]
king resentence son from america and my
mom's
and his moms children this is your
brother
hey kwai i'm sorry i slept with your man
this happened before we even met
it's not like you're the first man i've
ever been with i haven't
what did you just say about the other
men coming to america now it's coming to
me
i always thought that mika was going to
be queen a woman isn't allowed to lose
amunda it's the law
did it ever occur to you that megan
wanted to be your heir
would you dare banish me from my own
bedroom
[Applause]
i'm getting it from everywhere i am
upset in my family you
must be strong and general izzy would
love nothing more than to take over
zamunda raise it higher
[Laughter]
put your
i must admit your style is far into my
kingdom but it's impressive
that's right there you go let me hear
you say hey ho hey ho
no don't do that that's his
you too nephew
[Music]
you